- Hi, everyone.
Welcome to the Daily Homeroom live stream.
For those of y'all who are
wondering what this is,
when we started having
physical school closures,
we realized, when everyone
had to be socially distanced.
We realized that it's our duty really
as a not-for-profit with a mission
of free world class
education for anyone anywhere
to not only accelerate the development
of a lot of the software
tools and the content
but also try to create as
many supports as possible
for parents, teachers and students
as we go through this fairly tough time
and we've been running webinars
for teachers and parents
to understand how to use the different
Khan Academy resources and
we've been doing other things
but we thought it'd be fun
to have a way to connect
and stay synchronous
and have conversations
during this time of social distancing.
So welcome to this live stream.
I do like to make my
standard announcement.
Khan Academy is a not-for-profit.
We only can exist because
of philanthropic donations
from folks like yourself.
I wanna give a special shout
out to several corporations
that have stepped up in the
last few weeks to help us,
especially with the COVID response.
We were running at a deficit
even before the crisis
and our costs have gone up.
We're seeing about 2.5, 3X
the traffic we normally do.
We're trying to accelerate
a bunch of programs,
so special thanks to
Google, to Bank of America,
Google.org, AT&T, Fastly and Novartis
and to the many other philanthropic
and corporate supporters
pre-crisis as well,
who continue to support us
and special thanks to the
many thousands of people
who donate whatever they can,
$3, $5, it all makes a difference
and it all adds up because
it allows us to serve
many millions of students.
So today we've been having
some incredible guests
and I'm sorry to announce
that today's guest
is not so impressive, it's me.
So (laughs)
every now and then, we like
to mix in having guests
and just a time for you to ask me anything
you would like to ask me
and I say that in the
broadest possible terms.
I have yet to be offended by a question,
although I don't wanna
encourage you too much
but please on YouTube and
Facebook, ask me anything
and we have team members who are looking
at the message boards on
both YouTube and Facebook
to surface any questions.
And so already there's one from Facebook,
Cassava Raman asks, "Hi, Sal,
please answer my questions."
Well, I am answering it right now.
"How did you study and how
did you recommend studying?
"Please give a comparison
on effectiveness."
Well, I'll tell you what
that worked for me growing up
and even today, a lot of people ask me,
"Sal, how do you make a
lesson on organic chemistry
"and a lesson on the Napoleonic Wars
"and a lesson on Physics?"
Some of those subjects,
I have a deep intuition
and I know from my academic background
but a lot of them I have
to study to learn well.
And so whether it was when I was in school
or even now when I'm studying,
I have a very active process.
When I'm doing one, I like
if I'm doing something,
especially in math or the sciences,
I like to work through problems
and sometimes it's problems
I can find in a textbook
or on say, Khan Academy
and sometimes it's problems
I'm coming up with myself.
I was like, well, exactly,
how does a lead to b?
So my number one thing is
while you are studying,
constantly ask yourself questions
and even in a subject matter like history
where you say, okay, I have to read
this fairly dense chapter
of my history textbook
to understand or to get a
sense of the context of things,
constantly asking yourself questions
like why did Julius
Caesar cross the Rubicon?
Did he really think he could do it?
And what that does is one,
it forces connections...
Frankly, it just makes
everything more interesting
but you're also going to retain a lot more
because you're engaging more
of your brain on that concept.
So it's not just about memorizing
Julius Caesar crossed the
Rubicon in such and such a date
but when you start to
put yourself in his shoes
and say, okay, what's
the risk reward here?
Would I have done the same
thing in that situation
or if you're in biology class,
well, why does that make sense?
Or just even experiencing the awe of it.
When you study the cell and you realize
it's almost like a whole
civilization in there,
it's so much complexity and there's so...
It puts you in awe of how
everything all works together
and I think when you study
with that type of a mindset,
not only is the studying more effective
but it is more enjoyable.
I would say one key though is to not do it
in a stressed state and to do that,
it's all about building a habit
so that you're able to learn consistently
and do, depending on your age
level or what you're studying,
20, 30, 40 minutes every day,
try to make it as active as possible
and then what you see is by
the time you get to a test,
it'll feel intuitive
versus if you cram it,
six hours, the night before the exam.
And even if you're
studying on Khan Academy,
if you're watching a video,
always try to pause the
video, try to do it yourself,
whether it's me or someone
else making the video
before we work through it.
Try to see whether you could even come up
with some of the intuitions
about it before we explain it
and even if you do, you
watch the whole video,
then stop and say, okay, let
me see if I can replicate
that thought process.
Let me see if I can explain it now.
Let me see if I can go through
that same worked example.
So the more active you
make it, the better.
See, other questions from
Emmanuel Peter asks from YouTube,
"Are you going to put a geography
course on Khan Academy?"
We don't, unfortunately
have near term plans
to do a geography course, Emmanuel.
I would love to eventually.
The vision of Khan Academy
is all of the core subjects.
We have Khan Academy kids
now, so really from pre-K
through elementary,
middle school, high school
and even the core college but
we do not have geography yet,
which I think is a very valuable course.
So hopefully one day
some of it is resources,
any philanthropists or
corporate sponsors out there
or individual donors, things
like middle school science,
geography, middle school
science is actually
one of the areas that we would really like
to find some supports for if we can.
We're starting to do stuff
in English and language arts
for grades two through eight
but that's another area
where we would love to
talk to potential sponsors
and the Khan Academy Kids Effort,
there was just this efficacy
study that came out.
It was a randomized controlled trial,
which means they randomly put students
into one of two groups,
the control group or the treatment group
and in the control group,
they used a kind of a family friendly app.
These are five-year olds, four-year olds
who come from high poverty families
and then the treatment group,
they used Khan Academy kids,
20 minutes a day and the treatment group
after I think it was
about a month and a half,
they were completely, they
were able to close the gap
between some of these really
high-need communities,
these high-need students and
their more affluent peers.
So these students went from
roughly the 30th percentile
to the 50th percentile
in a week and a half.
So that's another area that
I would love to add more
if we can find the resources.
It goes up to first
grade, I would love to add
to second grade, third grade
and then internationalized
but no geography just yet.
Okay, from Facebook Asmar Avil asks,
"Hi, I'm new to using
Khan Academy Kids app."
Oh, well, we were just talking about that.
" or Khan Academy app, do you
have both both apps in Arabic?
"I did a quick search and I found
"you have a website in Arabic
"but I actually couldn't find it.
"Any clarification as
much is appreciated."
So thanks for asking Asmar.
So unfortunately we do not
have either app in Arabic yet.
We do have many localization
projects around the world.
You can imagine though,
languages like Arabic
and Farsi and Hebrew and Urdu,
they are right to left
and sometimes bi-directional languages
and we haven't been able to
build that into our product yet.
That is one of our to-dos
that we hope to be able to do
one day.
With that said, there
is a translation project
of Khan Academy into Arabic
and I think if you do Google search,
you should be able to find
that translation project.
So it's not the full functionality,
it's not the exercises and all of that
but at least the videos,
there are versions
that have been either
dubbed or redone in Arabic.
So, definitely try to see if
you can find those resources.
Elliot H. from YouTube says,
"Did you have any earlier
startups that failed?"
Simple answer is yes.
I have had my share of failures.
I don't even remember them all.
I'm someone that probably I've always had
a few hair-brained schemes
as early as I remember.
I remember in college,
I was trying to start,
actually we won some
business plan competitions.
I was trying to start an effort...
Looks at my internet connection
is doing weird things right now.
I hope you all can hear me
but in college I started an effort that,
it was actually around education,
where if you have an EEG which can measure
kind of mental activity,
can measure the various
cycles of brainwaves,
that if students are able to
stay focused on something,
say doing math problems,
it would reward them
and that if they lose
their focus while doing it,
it would say, "Hey, come back, stop, stop.
"Come look at what, stay
focused on the problem."
So, we'd call it Cerebral Technologies
but we never got too far with that.
Then, during my first job on the side,
I was trying to, I had
decided this was in the early,
this was in the late 90s.
I had this idea of locally
scoped domain names.
There's obviously domain
names for the whole world
but like, what about pizza.com?
What, shouldn't that go to
your local pizza parlor,
not just to some random
global pizza place?
So that was the idea, that you
could get these domain names,
would they go to different places
depending on where you are?
We got a little far but
that didn't go too far
and then I joined a
startup in the late 90s
called MiVC and this was
a legitimate startup.
It had venture funding and all the rest
and I was their kind of their CTO
and it got pretty far,
we grew to 40 people.
We actually, the whole
idea was to democratize
venture capital and the reason
why they even needed a CTO
is that we were building a platform
so that anyone who invested even a dollar
into the venture capitalist funds,
in the venture capital
funds could see what,
understand the entrepreneurs,
understand the businesses
that they were investing in,
things like that
but then the NASDAQ
collapsed, what was it?
In spring of 2000 and that's when I said,
"Maybe I should go to business school
"and then even..."
And actually even before business school,
me and a buddy tried to,
we started this thing called Truth Bites,
which in hindsight, we
probably should have kept that.
It was pre-the big social media wave
but it was essentially, you
sign up all your friends
and you could ask
questions that you normally
feel less comfortable being open about
and you could answer them
with some level of anonymity
and it was kind of a
way to foster more open
and vulnerable
communication between folks.
So that's just some of my
list of startups, (laughs)
failed startups and actually there's more.
There's actually, I joined a hedge fund
out of business school and
it was called Wool Capital.
It was just me and my boss, Dan
and we ended up hiring a few more analysts
and it did very well but
then Dan decided to retire
and he encouraged me to start my own fund.
And so I literally took over
his expenses and his team,
his office, which was very expensive.
It was costing a lot of money
and I started something called
Conduct Capital management
and that was a month before fall of 2008
where essentially the entire
stock market collapsed.
And I still I'm a little
defensive about it
because Conduct Capital did exist.
It existed for about eight months
and even in that year,
we were up 4% in a year
that the market was down 40%.
So, that's my slight
insecurity trying to justify.
It failed despite performance
but it obviously wasn't an environment
where people were interested in investing
in a new investment fund
and so that actually, that was a tough one
'cause that actually,
we burned a lot of our
savings frankly, on that.
So that was actually
one of the harder ones.
I can laugh about it in hindsight.
And then Khan Academy, so yes.
I think that's actually a
pretty comprehensive list
but a good question.
So Maya Sharma from YouTube
says, "Are we in a recession
"and what stocks should we invest in?"
So the first part is easy to answer.
I think the simple answer is yes.
In a recession there's multiple
strict definitions of it but
it's usually two quarters
of kind of reduced economic growth,
obviously because of the quarantines
and then even once we're,
the stay in place orders
and then even once we're out of it,
people's behavior is going to change.
They're going to travel less,
they're going to go to restaurants less,
even the restaurants that are open,
they're gonna have to have less capacity
'cause they're gonna have
to be socially distanced.
So you're definitely, and you just look
at the unemployment numbers,
not just in the US, around the world.
And so it's very clear
we're for sure in a recession already
and unfortunately the question is,
how bad will it be?
I'm not in the investment world anymore.
We've had some interesting
folks like Ray Daleo
and Mellody Hobson who are
some of the top investors
in the world on this live stream
and from what I hear from them,
there's definitely...
The stock market's incredibly
volatile right now.
That's very hard to time when you get in
but when there is a lot of volatility
and a lot of emotions in the market,
that is a time that
interesting opportunities
can sometimes get lost in the fray.
So I would say if you are
diligent and you look for things
and you look for things
that have a good thesis
and a thesis that can do
well in any type of economy,
you might find some diamonds
in the rough, so to speak.
But I do say that,
I know how sophisticated
many investors are
and I know all of the
work that we used to do
when I was an analyst at a hedge fund
and so I'm actually afraid
to be a stock picker today
because I know that
there's a version of myself
on the other side of that trade
who's doing a lot more
analysis than I have the time
to do right now.
So most of most...
I do it for 401K.
That's passively, it's
just an index things
but most of my savings,
I use it to pay down our mortgage
and to, we do have like a
rental property (laughs)
and I don't know, I have no idea
how that's all going to play out
with what's going on.
It's gonna be a tough, my best prediction,
it's gonna be a tough
couple of years coming up.
So yeah, I definitely would shy away
from doing anything very risky
but this is not a place for me
to give you too much investment advice,
take it all with a grain of salt.
So, Zaria Khan from YouTube,
not a question just a comment
says, "I remember seeing
him younger than this,"
So yes, I guess I've aged.
Thank you for pointing that out. (laughs)
In fairness, many years of you
might remember Khan Academy,
Sal Khan from 2008, 2009.
That's when we first
started really getting
on people's radars and
it's been 11 years since
and so I try to wear the cream
and the lotion and sunscreen
but we all age (laughs)
and the beard I heard, 'cause
it's gray, it has gray in it.
So whatever, it's a trade off.
These are good questions and comments.
From YouTube, Michelle Mitchell says,
"Hi, Sal, how did you
pick a major in college?"
Good question, Michelle.
So, for me, well, I'll tell
you what my thinking was
when I was maybe your age
if you are picking that major right now.
I guess you could say I was a romantic
in that when I was in high
school, I was convinced,
I was obsessed with physics.
I said, I wanna be a theoretical physics,
a PhD one day, I wanna
ponder the nature of reality.
I wanna answer the big questions
and even in my college applications,
when they said, what
do you wanna major in?
I said, "Physics, theoretical physics,"
and when I got to college,
it was actually around that
same summer before college,
there was a local professor
that found out that I had
a lot of interest in math
and computing and also found out
that I didn't have a computer.
And so he had access to computers.
So he gave me a summer internship
and so I was able to
essentially learn to code
using a proper computer,
actually quite good computers.
These kinds of mini computers
that are one step up
above PC type, back then in the mid 90s
and that's where I started
getting a real love
for computing and I said,
"Well, there's something
"about programming where
you can create realities,"
and people even debate
whether the reality we live in
is a simulation but that
kinda got me excited
about, hey, could you create realities?
Could you create experiences?
And there was also something about
technology and programming
that I liked is that
it could scale.
If you create an interesting
experience in theory,
an unlimited number of people could use it
and that was pretty compelling.
And so I decided to become
a computer science major
and math major at the same time
and that's the path I went down
and as I got further in my undergrad,
I started thinking about,
well, what about money?
And I didn't come from a wealthy family.
My mother made, I think, $16,000 in 1993
and the only reason why I remember that
is I had to do her taxes so
that I could get financial aid.
So I remember the number very clearly
and so, I was...
MIT was very generous
with the financial aid
but I still was incurring about,
give or take about $10,000 a year in debt
and that was a lot of money for my family.
And so near the end of my undergrad,
I started thinking very seriously about,
how do I pay this back?
How do I start making money?
How do I help out my family?
And I was going to do a master's
but I kind of hurried that up
by taking a few more classes
and the good thing is it was the late 90s
and I hadn't really thought about it much
but kind of CS was a very,
it was a very in demand
career as it continues to be.
So it worked out financially.
Actually I'll take that back.
I sound like I didn't
think about it at all.
I think, when you come from
fairly humble circumstances,
I don't think you oftentimes
even allow yourself
to go into a field that might be viewed
as a little less than practical.
So I think that was definitely
one of the constraints for me.
If I were giving advice to
you or to a family member
who's 17, 18 years old, 19 years old
and thinking about their major,
I would say,
especially in the economy
that we're about to go
in, look at the fields
that there's demand for.
I know this sounds like
very pragmatic advice
'cause it is but
if you're able to kinda
put money on the table,
food on the table, however
you wanna describe it
and you feel productive,
that is going to open up
a lot more things to you in your life.
And so, everyone talks about computing now
and obviously if that's
something you're excited about,
definitely go into it
but there's a lot of
other interesting areas.
Growing up, I thought
something like accounting
is kind of, that's been
counting, et cetera, et cetera
but then when I went to business school,
I discovered that finance and accounting
are fascinating subjects
and that's why actually why
I had this career transition
into investing.
So I think there's a lot of things
that we very easily can get
programmed by stereotypes.
You might have a friend
or family member who said,
"Oh, no, don't go into that.
"Those people are like this or like that,"
or, "That career is
boring," but give it a shot.
And almost any field,
if you put yourself in the right mindset
actually can be fascinating.
So that's the best advice I could give
but definitely try to come out
of college with some skills
that you think have a good chance of,
you're gonna be able to pay off your debt
and things like that.
I do have people in my family
and this is just a microcosm
for the whole country.
I don't think colleges
talk to freshmen enough
about the implications of the debt
and that how it can stay
with you a very long time
and I don't think they give
enough data to freshmen
and sophomores who are picking
their majors to tell them,
okay, people who majored in X,
what are their job prospects
like when they graduate?
How much are they making?
What percentage of them
have paid off their debt?
What percent of them are
in default of their debt,
10 years out, 15 years out?
And I know these are
kinda buzzkill answers
but I think it's super important.
So, if you can try to do some
of that research yourself,
talk to people who go to your college
and say, try to find alumns
who are in the major you're interested in,
they're one year out, five
year out, 10 year out,
10 years out and I think
there'll be very frank with you.
Some of them will say,
"It was the best decision
"I ever made to major in X,"
and some will say, "Ah, it's
not as easy as I thought
"to make a living in this X,"
or maybe I am making a living
but the subject matter is one thing
but then the job is a different thing.
So that's the best advice I could give.
I will give a plug.
Bank of America has been a
long time sponsor of work
we've been doing in financial
literacy and in careers
and so look up Khan Academy careers
and better money habits at Bank of America
and you'll actually see
a bunch of video profiles
of people in different careers
and understanding the trade offs in them.
Okay, so Abijith Paccar
says, "What inspires you
"to learn various topics?"
Well, for me, we're in
this mystery called life
and I've said it before
on this live stream,
there's been thousands of years
of accumulated human knowledge
and most of the things
that are now a paragraph
in your textbook or a
video on Khan Academy,
that's oftentimes the culmination
of many people's lifetime work
and they would do anything,
they would have done anything
to have access to that information
and so I always remind myself,
there's something interesting about this,
that someone wanted to
devote their life to
and there usually is.
The science, any subject.
When you look at literature
and how it can evoke human emotions
and transport you to another time
or another even perspective,
that's somewhat magical.
If you look at the sciences,
they really are all about understanding
the nature of our reality,
the nature of life,
the nature of how all,
just a handful of elements can combine
in different ways to
form a Sal or an Abijith.
These are mind blowing things
so that's what gets me excited
and obviously I have an extra motivation
that if I can really digest it
and stay excited about
it, then I can hopefully
be a little bit infectious with that
and help other people get
excited about it as well.
So, from Joanna Mina, from Facebook,
"Sal, do you have
suggestions how to keep kids
"engaged in online school?
"Sometimes they study to have
good grades for their teachers
"but while studying from home,
"they don't have the
engagement with other humans
"and lose interest."
You're asking a super
important question, Joanne
and I won't pretend like I've
solved all of it at home.
My older children, they go to school
that I helped start called Khan Lab school
and they've done a really good job
of essentially helping young people.
My kids are 11, eight and five
and especially the 11 and eight year old,
who've been in kind of in the system
where there's been a lot
of emphasis on agency.
Students set their goals
but then once a week,
they check in with their
teachers to review their goal.
So there is accountability around it
but that muscle that they've
been building over many years,
even pre-COVID, it seems to
be serving them well right now
and their teachers are
doing an incredible job,
kind of keeping it going over the course
of this situation we're in.
So I do see even young kids
as young as seven, eight,
nine years old,
if they're used to that muscle of,
okay, you have a set number
of goals for the day,
for the week, for the term
and that there's a daily
and then maybe weekly or maybe
quarterly or term check-in,
that actually can be pretty good
and then on the day to day,
I think it's all about structure.
It's all about habit.
Our five-year-old has been
maybe the most difficult
but even with him, the
more we get the structure
and the habit and we
celebrate the small wins
and we make sure there's
a lot of time for breaks
and we don't try to do too much at once.
We say, "Hey," for the five-year-old.
If we can get a productive
hour and a half today,
that's a win.
And then once we get into the habit
of that productive hour and a half,
we're going to keep going
but then for my older kids,
it's all about just making
sure they have balance,
even in these times of social distancing,
that they have time to go outside,
that they have time to play.
They have time to do creative things
that while they're doing
their independent work
or their zoom sessions
with their teachers,
that they're taking breaks,
they're stretching and things like that.
That's the best I can give,
there's other resources.
We've had parents and teacher webinars
that go into much more depth on this
and obviously we've released things
like daily schedules and learning plans
to help with some of this
but I think those check ins
with both parents and teachers
that hold the students
a little bit accountable
and they know they're gonna come,
that helps them build that muscle.
So I would just say stick to it.
It can sometimes be a
little messy at first
but over time, if there's a silver lining,
is that students could
build more of that agency
and that independence muscle.
So let's see.
From, Afthab Khan from
Facebook, "Any plans in India?"
We actually have a whole team in India,
Khan Academy, India team.
There's several folks in
Delhi and in Bangalore.
So yeah, simple answer's is we have plans.
I could go over the whole Indie effort
but if you do some web searches on it,
you should be able to find our India...
We have a Hi-English
version of Khan Academy,
which is for those who
don't know Hi-English,
it's a hybrid between Hindi and English.
We're translating into,
on redoing actually
in many of the languages in India,
we're mapping to many
of the state standards.
So India is actually
one of our geographies
that we're very focused on.
The other is Brazil, Spanish
speaking Latin America
and that has, as I mentioned,
there's 45 translation projects
from mainly volunteers around the world.
So Adam Bupkari asks, "Is
it possible to take the SAT
from Khan Academy?"
You could prepare for
the SAT from Khan Academy
but the administration
is not on Khan Academy
but I highly recommend,
even if you're not
taking the SAT right now,
when we partnered with
the Cardboard on this,
we said, we don't want this
just to be superficial test prep,
we want this to be something
that really helps students
become more college ready,
improves their mathematical
critical thinking,
their reading comprehension,
their writing skills.
So actually our SAT practice,
the official SAT practice on Khan Academy,
I actually think it's a great
thing for anyone for sure.
Any high school students and even maybe
some middle school
students to start doing,
putting in half an hour
a day, 40 minutes a day.
If you do that, I think you're gonna find
that you're gonna really
build those muscles,
especially through this
kind of COVID crisis
and through the summer
and then when you happen
to take the SAT, you're
just gonna be like,
"Oh, this all makes sense."
This is all pretty straightforward
and frankly, you'll just be
that much more college ready.
So, from YouTube explorer questioner,
unorthodox question for Sal,
"Do you perhaps garden?"
A little bit, my wife is the gardener
and she would like me
to be more of a gardener
and, so I'm trying to garden more.
My wife does a wonderful job.
We have a very pleasant garden,
maybe one day I'll do our livestream
from our backyard
but I definitely see the appeal
but I just haven't...
If I claim to do any gardening,
if my wife is watching,
she would roll her eyes.
So I won't make claims
that I can't back up.
From YouTube, Anglo Indian
boy, "Do you play chess?"
I do but I play at a,
I would say, I'm a very good amateur
and my 11 year old son is getting,
we're about even now.
So he's on the site, Chess Kids,
which I have to give credit, it's,
he spends time on that every...
Whenever I win, he goes
and learns new things,
new openings and new strategies
and then he comes back and
then he usually beats me.
He's on definitely a
much faster trajectory
and I think we're about a year away
where he might,
I might not be able to beat him anymore
but yeah, I would consider myself
a good amateur chess player
but I definitely love the game.
Let's see.
Well I do say, I mean, I
will brag a little bit,
there was at this event in Silicon Valley,
Magnus Carlsen was there, a chess champion
for those of you who
don't know of the world.
And he offered to play
four people blindfolded,
and my name was picked from
the hat of the people there.
So I was one of the four people
who got to play Magnus Carlsen.
He was blindfolded and playing
four of us at the same time
but I was the last person standing.
So there was, he took
care of the other three
and then he's obviously blindfolded
and there was a moment in the game,
where I actually had an advantage,
but then when his entire
chess brain power was focused on me,
I could almost like feel it
and it was incredibly intimidating.
And then I just panicked and he won,
not to say that he wouldn't
have won if I didn't panic,
(laughs)
Favorite board game.
We're all out of time
but I can go a little bit longer.
I think I have time.
What's your favorite board game,
from Alexander Ticevich,
sorry if I'm mispronouncing
your name Alexander from Facebook.
I'm a big fan of Risk,
Monopoly and Settlers of Catan
but with all of them, they get much better
if you add kind of a
notion of markets to them.
So I've have a version
of Risk that I play.
It's kind of a paranoia Risk where,
paranoia Risk is where every army is,
their goal is to try to remove
another army from the board
but you don't know who's
trying to remove you
and so you could imagine
there's a lot of intrigue
and what you do is you can
create stocks for each color,
and then you can have
another separate group
of 20 to 30 people, trading securities.
So if that color wins,
it's worth a hundred
at the end of the game, if
they lose it is worth zero.
And so at any given point in time,
the value of that color trading
should be the probability
that they win the game.
That's a fun thing.
In Monopoly, I like to
add notions of investors.
So there's even people who are,
they're willing to take equity stakes
in various players,
you can introduce things
like insurance contracts,
debt instruments in monopoly.
So I think that's pretty,
corporate structures
so that you can have multiple
investors in like the shoe.
(giggling)
So that's a fun way to,
and in Settlers of Catan,
you can actually, there's
something I used to do
in summer camps I used to run
with middle school students.
You can play Settlers of
Catan with no trading,
you could play trading at your board.
Then you can play trading
where you have other boards,
and then you could trade.
You can kind of do that
as international trade
and then you could introduce
some form of currency
and then what's interesting
is you can see it
on every one of those steps,
more trade, will create more building
and more currency will
create more building
just 'cause there's, more people are able
to get what they need.
So it's a good way of understanding money
and the value of trade.
So other questions here,
and I know we're all out of time
so I'll answer one or two more.
So Josie Mubarak from YouTube says,
"Given the COVID-19 has, given the effect
"it's had on primary
and secondary schools,
"what has been the effect on
the Khan Academy platform?"
Well, Josie we've seen
our traffic be about,
depending on the date, 250%
to 300% of normal traffic.
So we've definitely seen
a huge increase in load
on the platform.
I guess that's the main effect,
the effect on the organization,
obviously as the organization,
everyone is now working remotely
and people are dealing with their own...
Some people have young kids,
I have young kids at home
but I have a lot of
support at home as well
but you could imagine a lot
of folks have young kids
and so we're trying to work
with all of our team members
to make sure that they
feel fully supported
as they have all of
these competing tensions.
And just as an organization,
we're trying to accelerate forward
as many things as we can do.
But as I said earlier,
most of our resources
come from philanthropy, so that's a lot,
that's very front of mind these days
is making sure we can raise enough money
to do the things we're already doing,
especially to the earlier question,
we're going into harder economic times,
who knows what happens to donations
over the next couple of months?
So I'm definitely, that's
some, a little thing
that I sometimes wake up and think about
and how could we potentially
get more resources
so that we can accelerate even more,
add more subject areas, improve
our platform, et cetera.
So that's kind of the stuff
that at the Khan Academy level
we've been thinking about.
So Bobby Lynn, Joseph Caret
from Facebook, it's very nice.
It's not a question,
it's sounds like they...
Oh, it says a teacher.
So I know we're a week past
Teacher Appreciation Week,
but thanks Bobby Lynn, Joseph
Caret for being a teacher.
It sounds like, you're
really into Khan Academy.
Thank you for that.
So let's see, there is
so many good questions.
This is an explorer question,
or you're asking really
interesting questions,
"Sal, where in the U.S would
be a good place to live
"for a lifelong learner?"
I've actually had this,
I've gone through this
thought experiment before in my life,
'cause as you can imagine,
Silicon Valley is not
a cheap place to live
and when Khan Academy was
just me in a walk in closet,
and we were living off of savings,
I used to look at other
places in the country
that had a nice climate,
that had a better cost of living
and thought about whether
I should move there or not
with a family.
So there's some nice places in...
Well, there's nice places everywhere
but I definitely, San Diego
is now quite expensive too
but it is cheaper than the Bay area
but the Bay area is actually a great place
for a lifelong learner.
The cost of living is very high
but as I say, your backyard
because the weather is good.
You can do that as one of
the rooms of your house.
So, that makes it a little bit better.
Yeah, there's a lot of places,
depends what you look for.
For me, it's really who
you surround yourself with.
Do you have a good friend,
friendships, community?
Are there other people
who intellectually stimulate you around?
If you have that, almost anywhere
can be pretty incredible.
So, let's see.
I guess, let's see are
there any other questions?
Well, there's so many,
I feel like going through all of this
but I'm guessing I'm
missing a meeting right now.
I've been guilty of that before.
Let's see, Sammy Sultana,
"What inspired you to study at MIT?"
Well, I don't wanna
make this a big MIT ad.
I think there's many great universities
but it was, I'll tell you the story.
When I was seven years old,
my mother's second to youngest brother,
so my uncle at the time,
who we were living with him in a while
but anyway, we were at his house.
I remember this, I was seven years old
and he was in college at the
university of New Orleans.
And I remember him doing some math
and I remember being intrigued
'cause it looked just
like random symbols to me.
I was like, his name is Dal Shadmamu.
Mamu in our language means
uncle, mother's brother.
So I said, "Dal Shadmamu, what is this?"
And he said, "Sal, this is calculus,"
and I was like, "What is calculus?"
And he's like, "Well,
it's this math where..."
He tried to explain and then I said,
"Can you teach me calculus?"
And he's like, "Well, no, I don't know
"if I can teach you calculus,"
and I was like, "Why do you
need to learn calculus?"
And he's like, "Well, I'm
studying to be an engineer,"
and I said, and I remember
this super vividly.
And I said, "Well, what
does an engineer do?"
And he's like, "Well, an
engineer builds things
"to solve problems in the world."
Like he wanted to become
a mechanical engineer,
and then I said, "Well, then
I wanna be an engineer too,"
and then he says, "Well, if
you wanna be an engineer,
"you should go to MIT,"
and he doesn't remember.
I've told him this story many times.
He has no recollection of the story
but I had no idea what MIT
was, what it stood for,
where it was but something
just entered into my brain,
based on what my uncle's
five-minute conversation
with me when I was seven.
I was like, "Oh, I should go there,"
and I remember in high school,
in ninth or 10th grade,
it just kind of stayed
in the back of my mind
and then when I talked to the
guidance counselor about it,
the guidance counselor's like,
"Sal, you gotta up your
game a little bit."
Not that I was not a good student
but I grew up in Louisiana
and there's probably about
five kids a year who go
and I didn't go to one of the
famous schools in the state.
And so, anyway, I was always
enamored by the notion,
and for me personally,
it was wonderful place.
There's a lot of, it's a place...
I gave a commencement address
at MIT a couple of years ago
and I said, it's the
closest thing I can think of
on the planet to like Hogwarts,
where you can debate
whether there's real magic
in the world, but a place
where people are focused on
creating cool things
that could help humanity
and are creative about it
and are very accepting of
people's eccentricities.
I thought was really nice
and I've obviously made
some of my best friends
from college and I met my wife there.
So I definitely, I had a good experience
but obviously I think any experience,
one thing I've learned in life is,
it's not where you go,
it's not all of these things
we often put a lot of importance on,
it's the energy that you project outward.
So if you go, wherever you go to college,
if you say, "Hey, I am so lucky.
"I get to be in an environment
"that is focused on learning,
"an environment where I can meet friends
"and bond and be open."
If you put that energy out there,
the friendships will happen.
You will learn, you will explore.
People will gravitate to you.
But if you go with kind
of a cynical attitude
and you're like,
"Oh, these people are
out to compete with me,"
or, "Oh, this isn't my
first choice school,"
or things like that.
Then it'll kind of be a
self-fulfilling prophecy.
So I would say, regardless
of where you wanna go,
obviously I only had
one college experience
and that was MIT
and I really enjoyed it.
But what I found, whether
it's at MIT or other places,
there were people who didn't
have a good experience
and oftentimes it might've been
because it came with some
cynicism to it or whatever.
And so, that's my best advice.
It's not going this school or that,
it's the attitude that you bring to it.
So we're all out of time.
I'm enjoying hamming it
up with y'all right now
and y'all are asking some
really good questions
but we'll have more of these,
Ask Sal Anything sessions in the future.
So thanks a bunch for joining
and everyone have a wonderful weekend.
Thanks for joining the live stream.
I'll see y'all on Monday.